um I first saw Charles Burnett's
landmark film killer of sheep in high
school when my brother was a filmmaker
as well was putting together a
distribution collective for black
independent films back though back then
you couldn't see those film in theaters
one of those films in that collective
was killer of sheep even at the time I
was aware of that it was a privilege to
get a chance to see this movie and it
blew my mind on multiple levels the
black and white cinematography was
gorgeous the competition the
compositions were stunningly beautiful
and the music choices were impeccable
and to a small kid growing up in a whole
black town in the Midwest the characters
were utterly relatable the weight of the
film show Beauty and the midst of
despair remind me of the great
theologian smoked song ugly Beauty but
the work of art that I think bears the
closest resemblance to the film as a
whole is actually the great novel by
Ralph Ellison Invisible Man Ralph
Ellison does not have a large body of
work but no one questions the fact that
Invisible Man is one of the greatest
books of the 20th century and in that
same way that Invisible Man is a great
piece of American literature killer of
sheep is a great piece of American
cinema
killer of sheep does a very rare thing
it portrays a particular subculture with
great clarity accuracy and cultural
specificity and in doing so Craig's a
drama that is universally relatable
I've known Charles for many years he's a
quiet gentleman with a huge heart and it
is an incredible pleasure to get to see
him presented with an Oscar tonight on
behalf of the Academy Board of Governors
congratulations
[Applause]